se désister c'est maintenant ou jamais
[Musique]
apparemment l'hôtel aurait fermé en 2008
cf comment 9 ans le truc c'est ce
complètement délabré
[Musique]
ouais c'était une sorte de salle karaoké
sa [ __ ] dans l'hôtel il y avait des
salles pour chanter des salles karaoké
mon maire ici une petite pancarte avec
des notes de musique est juste là une
sorte de sono et puis même c'est
vachement ambiance salle pour chanter
quoi c'est sûr c'est un karaoké monga
sûr et certain donc tout à l'heure on
était de l'autre côté de ce mur dans les
cuisines et là on est dans le réfectoire
l'eau les gens de manger soit 1 il ya
encore la sauce soja de l'époque
bon allez pas en bonne état kadhafi en
fait en bas de l'hôtel il ya un fleuve
et du coup je pense qu'il ya bouyer
beaucoup d'humidité dans l'hôtel c'est
pour ça que c'est délabré à ce point et
c'est triste parce que l'hôtel il avait
une super vu en fait en phase totale
abandonné il ya un hôtel non abandonner
qui est immense donc je pense que
celui-là il a résisté à la crise mais
celui dans lequel on met non justement
dans l'endroit le plus dangereux de
l'hôtel mon gars [ __ ] j'ai besoin
combien on va toucher on va se diriger à
la réception ce qu'on a vu une sorte de
fausse biche hyper glauque
ça nous a tous intrigué
et voilà
c'est l'élément le plus glauque de
l'hôtel c'est sûr ils avaient quand même
plus le temps d'en bas les quelques
meubles
mais ils les ont laissées sur place sais
pas pourquoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le moment est venu de faire des squats
parce qu'être racistes dans un lieu
aussi étroit se compliquer du coup je
vais tallec le mans jd vu qu'on est les
deux seuls sol baisse vidéo et par à 3
heures du matin du coup distribution des
talkie walkie salut c'est jean-michel ça
va globalement on a fait la réception et
des salons sait pas trop ce que c'est et
là on va faire les chambres de l'hôtel
la réception et au cinquième étage de
l'hôtel et plus bas ce sont les chambres
tu sais ce qui sera plus présent on
assure au nom est l'enfant avec la cour
et l'asiatique est déjà quand tu te
retrouves à 2 tu as vu du monde c'est
bien mais ça c'est une chambre un fait
mais c'est la première chambre que je
vois un mec c'est un peu oppressant en
fait de dormir dans ce total pour fêter
les héros lumière genre tu dors entre
quatre murs complètement fermé alors
toutes les fenêtres sont en fait à la
réception et au voir ça à couper le
souffle
m c'est juste dire combien je suis pas
très sûr moi j'ai jamais fait ça [ __ ]
il ya des moisissures il ya des
moisissures à fond les yucatan
trop bon honnêtement ils sont super boon
edam mais ces immenses et une suite
royale c'est quoi ça aux maigres regarde
c'est des photos de l'auteur avant
qu'ils soient abandonnées [ __ ] t'as vu
ça juste ici c'est un en scène au pied
d'une fenêtre mais déjà je l'attends il
ya un plan moi je pense que c'est en bas
à quoi que il ya des six-jours rca côté
de la rivière je pensais tout embarqué
on cherche d'autres trucs pas si tout ça
de la pub un jeu de la pub 2008
ici on a une sorte de wes des annonces
soient des tunes pour les besoins pour
ce qu'il a à faire dans la région truc
tory ce type d'accord j'espérais qu'on
trouve le prix d'une chambre type de ces
morts et ça je pense que c'est une bonne
chambrée site a vu à vue sur le lac et
tomorrow personnes maintenant on va
s'enfoncer dans des étages qu'on n'a pas
du tout vu et j'aimerais bien tomber sur
les hauts-de-seine [ __ ] même s'il ya
plus d'eau quoi que ce soit j'aimerais
bien voir à quoi ça ressemble en fait en
plus et du carrelage donc peut-être que
saab était mieux conservée que genre la
moquette ou le hula le papier peint
voiture plus on descend et plus les
étages sont délabrés j'ai l'impression
que tu avais peut rien par terre tout et
tout et [ __ ] quoi assez mal en plus on
est en fond c'était horrible tiens si on
doit sortir on doit remonter là j'ai
hyper peur de tomber sur un corps en
fait en allant dans des chambres
regardez il ya encore les chaussons à
l'entrée quoi puisque japon en fait
avant d'entrer dans un appart ya
toujours une zone où tu retires tes
pompes et ensuite tu mets des chaussons
comme ça pour avancer
là bas je vois en maths la mecque mais
ça me fait un peu c'est un peu ça
j'étais cherche un point là hop indé cas
de la literie de façon c'est tellement
glauque mais qu au claf amis mais quand
on dit qu'on est venu les kidnappé en
pleine nuit il regarde c'est normal
d'avoir sa unique sans déconner il ya
encore la bouffe
j'arrive pas à comprendre comment les
lieux peuvent être abandonnés comme s'il
y avait des gens et on leur a dit allez
dégagez maintenant tout de suite tu vois
et sortir pyjama tu as bon ça c'est
typique au japon il ya plein de lieux
comme ça en fait au japon les gens on
n'est pas du tout les premiers à mener
dans ce bâtiment on n'est pas des
derniers mais les gens respectent les
lieux ils touchent rien il est où
exactement comme c'était au moment ils
sont entrés et du coup tu as des scènes
de vie en fait mais sans vie c'est
glauque fois à l'élite à la bouffe ta ta
le tattoo caire en état assez correcte
en fait tu vois tout cas placé comme si
les gens étaient partis hier on n'a pas
l'impression que c'était il ya neuf ans
les dernières personnes qui avaient loué
des chambres avant tout à fait du bruit
les autres n'ont eu peur non non non
c'est bien c'est pas mignon
on entend de l'eau écouter et un bruit
d'eau il ya un truc qui revit c'est
justement qu'on va trouver des beaux
arts où il vient juste de l'autre côté
en fait d'accord car il ya un autre côté
de ce mois ci une porte à des couloirs
de leur croisière ont fait le tour et là
c'est vraiment on s'éloigne de plus en
plus
outre les autres partis on est un peu
car du tout se passe bien pour vous
aubert de petite cuisine les make way
devrait bien pour nous on s'enfonce
petit à petit on cherche les
hauts-de-seine on est aux chambres 300
laquelle il a ouvert il ya un caillou de
l'autre côté maintenant que c'est pas la
partie de l'hôtel qui s'effraient benoît
nous expliquer qu'il ya une partie de
l'hôtel qui est tombé dans la rivière en
fait à un moment et du coup je pense que
on voit ici des roches extraites de ce
dernier fait j'ai pas gd kahn porte mais
que j'étais super peur c'est juste
dingue ce qu'on est en train de vie
[ __ ] un lieu abandonné aussi immense
tout ce que j'avais vu moi c'était au
mieux une petite maison tu vois je
n'avais jamais fait de bâtiments entiers
comme ça c'est juste dingue à découvrir
quoi au [ __ ] ils m'ont fait peur la
fsu faire faire les liens au mec
incroyable
la découverte la mascotte de la coupe du
monde de 1990 et ça vaut boire
c'est parce que ces textes endroit mais
il ait explosé tout ça va bien waouh
particules à l'évasion websense est en
dessous rapport au dernier étage allez
on y va voilà la recette les [ __ ] plus
on s'en fout des odeurs des odeurs
bizarres aller montanes no man's land
c'était cool comme en scène en vrai on
va y aller petit casier pour mettre ses
affaires personnelles donc là c'est là
où tu te douche
oui tu te laves en fait avant de
rejoindre le bain qui est ici est donc
en fait du coup ici taraba à 40 degrés
ici à 45 neumann il est plutôt 45 et ici
aussi j'ai rarement tu as juste un bas à
20 à 21 degrés une température normale
quoi donc ça c'est les bains pour hommes
ou les bains publics en fait j'ai foi ça
dépend des horaires des fois il ya des
bars et une mixte en fait succès des
hôtels et que c'est pas des des vrais
vrai en scène est vraiment il ya un
[ __ ]
et apparemment il ya aussi un hansen
pour les femmes qui est quelque part par
ici et les 1 100 féminin
oh et il essaie beaucoup plus beau avec
des petites fontaines et oum et b et là
c'est le capitanat elles ont carrément 1
cent contre les vitres regard ça mais à
tort mais c'est mais c'est magnifique
est ce qu'un jour
non mais je pense pas que ce soit le
thème des femmes les gars je pense que
ça fait le mix et la basse et les femmes
à mon avis c'est là où il ya tous les
bains contre les vitres en fait où tu
vois la rivière couler mais associé au
call you yeah sm les indications de qui
c'est son boulot tu vois ça indique je
pense de la température est pourquoi le
baril fait genre quand c'est très chaud
ce n'est pour se relaxer les muscles et
sert à tuer par lâcheté une énorme
connerie a essayé un exemple et bien les
amis comme jd vient de si bien le dire
on a terminé de visiter ces lieux
[Musique]
en
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais les amis merci pour ce moment
c'était une belle visite vous a trouvé
un très beau hôtel abandonné benoît
merci à toi votre problème c'était ouf
n'hésitez pas à les voir la chaîne de
tous ces gens ici présent que ce soit le
grand jeu dès que swan aux mânes que ce
soit benoit est abonné vous émettez
plein de pouce bleus sur leurs vidéos
comme ça n'hésitez pas à blida où ça
vous a plu
donc on a dû dormir tout de suite tu as
tout le monde pis incroyable
[Musique]